You've written a lot of interesting programs already and that's great. But one
capability that was lacking so far was to be able to ask the user to supply
input. Here's how you do it in Java. Just like you use System.out for output.
You use System.in to get input from the user. But as it turns out System.in is
not very smart and to really read numbers and strings from the keyboard you use
an object of the scanner class. You construct a scanner with a new operator,
new scanner and this is the scanner that can read from System.in. Usually, you
want to read more than one input, so it makes sense to save the scanner in a
variable. Here it is. It's called in and of course it's of type scanner. Then,
when the time has come to read something you call one of the methods of the
scanner class. Here, I called the nextInt method. It reads an integer that the
user types in. And returns it, and here I'm saving that integer in the age
variable. So, you should think of a scanner, kind of like a supermarket
scanner, except a supermarket scanner of course reads a bar code. And our
scanner here reads something from the user, and also produces some number. The
program snippet that I've written here is not quite complete. After all, how is
the user supposed to know that then I'll ask for their age. So, before calling
a scanner method that reads user input, you always want to alert the user first
with the statement such as this one. The string here, how old are you, is
called a prompt string. It prompts the user to then take the next step and
provide an input. Note that with the prompt string, we put a blank space here,
that just looks prettier, so that the users input is a little bit separated.
When you print the prompt it looks prettier when both the prompt and the user
input are on the same line. That's why we're using print and not println here.
And then, you want to have a blank space to separate the prompt from the user
input. Here, we write an integer, you can also read a decimal number by calling
nextDouble that returns a double. And again, you would then want to capture it
in a variable. Let me demo this in BlueJ, so you can see what it looks like
before you get to try it yourself.